I am hopeful there's a difference
between being optimistic and being
hopeful optimistic suggests that I
expect everything turn out right and I
have good vibes about everything hopeful
means that in spite of all the bad
things that you really do see that
really are out there you take the long
view and in a long view you have
confidence that right out I am hopeful i
have the long view the short run is
rather nasty brutish and short to quote
mr. Hobbs and that's my view of the
world this is a difficult tough place
and people will when given the
opportunity usually do the wrong thing
they'll try everything until the right
thing eventually comes along so I'm not
optimistic in the immediate sense that
you know I think there'll be peace in
the Middle East or that we will give up
our addiction to oil or will be nice to
our neighbor I'm not optimistic in that
sense I am hopeful in the long run that
we will find a way through all these
dispiriting realities and unhappy truths
we will find a way to make our way
through that and the only way that I can
think of that is think of things that
transcend that that's why reread every
two years saying agust in the city of
god there's a great moral there the
great ideal beyond this fallen world in
which we find ourselves it's why I still
believe in inspirational biographies I
saw the Pope Jesse Jackson you know give
home a chance keep hope alive and so on
so forth I'm not altogether sure that
the social or political process is the
way to do that but I think people need
to be possessed of powerful ideas and
ideals the almost impossible thing again
Don Quixote that gets people moving and
I'm convinced that that hope to be
hopeful is to be ultimately realistic in
in the face of every reason for despair
so that I am as mr. Kennedy once
described himself I am an idealist
without illusions I think it's a lovely
phrase
the univ on students gives me tremendous
hope I see an enormous range of talent
and opportunity in the students that
pass through my courses and through the
church and through the other settings in
which I meet young people here in across
the country I have tremendous hope in
the rising generation I believe in them
I believe not only are they in terms of
the mission statistics smarter than
their parents I believe that they are
less capable of being seduced by the
talents and the treasures of this world
that they have a higher standard at what
they want and what they feel they
deserve and what the world requires I
look to them to produce in some sense
this ideal world their parents have had
that chance and they squandered it
there's not much there that we had it
seems to me but in these young kids that
we produce regularly each year out of
colleges like this one I believe there
is the world's best jobs the world's
best hope that gives me cause for
encouraging